hey guys so I'm trying something a
little bit different today I'm making a
shorter less edited video because I love
making these bigger in-depth ones but
people have said they'd like to see more
frequency for me more regular uploads
and doing those longer videos the last
one I think was 16 minutes whilst I
loved doing it it takes a long time I
can't do more than one a week so I
thought what I'd do is one big in-depth
one a week and then one shorter one
where I discuss a topic in a little less
debt depth maybe some quick tip or a
quick point of discussion maybe a review
maybe something else like that maybe
some news and that way I can upload more
frequently while still maintaining the
quality of those bigger ones so this is
my first quick discussion it's going to
be on functional fixedness and let me
know what you think in the comments down
below have you ever wondered why it's so
satisfying when you watch Jackie Chan
pick up an umbrella or a ladder and use
that to beat up on guys that's because
we're witnessing inventiveness and
resourcefulness and I always say there's
no such thing as a lack of resources
only a lack of resource fulness I didn't
make up that quote by the way I just say
it a lot so the human brain is built for
efficiency and that means that it will
always take the easiest route to find
the answer this is where stereotypes
come from it's where over generalization
comes from because a lot of time
stereotypes and neighborhood
generalizations are accurate for
instance if you see a lion chances are
it's not a friendly line it's going to
eat you and the most efficient way of
your brain acting in that situation is
to assume that that line is just like
all the rest of the lines and to run
away but as we know this can sometimes
lead to errors in judgment and a
particular example of that is called
functional fixedness this is a type of
cognitive bias so functional fixedness
means that you can only think of a tool
in the context of what that tool or item
was originally designed for it has a
fixed functionality as far as you're
concerned so if you have a hammer you're
thinking this is used for driving nails
into wood it's not useful for anything
else and that of course means you might
miss out on other possible uses for it
and this is perfectly demonstrated by a
famous problem called the candle problem
in the candle problem participants are
presented with a hammer a box of tack
and that's it and they're told they need
to attach the candle so they also
presented with a candle and they're told
there needs to be attached the candle to
the wall using the hammer and the box of
tacks and it needs to be out of burn and
stay attached and light up the room so
what they'll normally do is take take
the hammer take the tacks and try and
drive the tacks through the candle into
the wall so that the candle stays
attached to the wall and the lights up
the room
of course this just breaks the candle it
won't work and what they actually need
to do is to empty the box of tacks use
the box as a kind of shelf nail that to
the wall and then stand the candle in
the box so in order to come to that
conclusion they've thought of that box
of tacks or something other than just a
box of tacks they thought of it as a
shelf they've overcome their functional
fixedness and this is the same kind of
thing we see when Jackie Chan sees an
umbrella and doesn't just see an
umbrella he sees something that he can
fight with it's also the same kind of
thing that we use in puzzle solving mode
and play computer games so in a computer
game say portal you're presented with a
tool say the portal gun and shown away
you can use it and then the puzzle comes
from coming up with a new problem and
then having to use that tool you've been
taught in a new and inventive way so
you're using the same tool the
overcoming of functional fixedness to
come up with a new way to use it
the real aha moment is when you have
that shift in perception that allows you
to view everything that's happened in a
new light so how can we make ourselves
overcome this functional fixedness have
more shifts in perception be more
resourceful
well according to studies that use the
candle problem it seems that the more
stressed we are and the more motivated
we are the less successful we are at
overcoming these kinds of problems and
that's because when we're very stressed
and very full of adrenaline and dopamine
we tend to be focused on just one answer
we just try and repeat that one solution
until we get what we want
on the other hand when you relax more
you can explore the myriad different
ideas and different options explore your
connectome and come up with something
entirely new of course in the case of
Jackie Chan he's doing all this in a
split instant in order to grab something
in his environment and use it in a
creative way and this demonstrates the
importance of being able to stay calm
and cool in a crisis and you can do this
not only
things like CBT but also meditation and
by improving your cardiovascular fitness
in order to lower your heart rate so
that your whole physiology is karma even
when you're exerting yourself and so
actually instead of being stressed when
you're trying to figure out the solution
to a problem what you actually do is
just walk away and then come back to it
and that's probably why I'll come with
my solutions to programming problems
when I get up to go to the loop and
there's another reason for this and
that's because when you change your
environment that creates a perception
shift because all these new neurons are
firing and allows you to view what
you're doing in a different way so the
doorway effect describes why we often
forget what we went into a room for and
that's because you've gone into a new
environment new neurons are firing and
therefore you forget the reason you went
in there your perspective has changed so
this could be used in a positive way
when you're stuck on a problem if you
just take a break and expose yourself to
a new environment then you can change
your way of thinking just enough to get
a new perspective on the issue there are
also a bunch of different protocols you
can use to give yourself a new
perspective often a good option is just
to ask yourself different questions
which will reframe the problem so you
might ask yourself how would my friend
bla solve this problem or how would I
solve this problem ideally if I had all
the tools I needed and this helps you to
think about it in a new and different
way one of the best options is simply to
run through all of them raw materials at
your disposal so instead of thinking
I've got a hammer
I've got tacks I've got a candle you now
think I've got string in the wick I've
got wax I've got wood I've got metal
then you think of all the different
tools you've got hammer box etc and all
the different ways you can use them
bashing things prying nails out of walls
using it for leverage etc and this way
you see more options and you can come up
with more solutions changing your
perspective on things is something that
the brain loves to do because it gives
us more options and of course using
tools is one of the things that helped
our evolution to a massive extent the
first time I picked up a stick and we
used it to fish for ants in a tree that
was an example of us overcoming
functional fixedness and developing
useful tools one of the best ways to
change your perception to get a shift in
perspective
is to seek moments of or this is called
or cultivation so when you're standing
on top of a mountain or when you're
faced with some exotic creature or when
you had something challenge your whole
belief system like an episode of planet
Earth - then you sometimes feel
incredibly small and you get this
incredible sense of wonder and awe
neurochemically this is the result of a
release of all kinds of hormones and
neurotransmitters and it might be
because your brain is having to
completely rethink its stance on so many
different things
rebuild reassess lots of different
networks because you're having to
rethink your position in the world it's
changed the way you've seen all kinds of
different memories and ideas that you've
had before it's such a grand data dump
that it changes much of your connectome
and this massive restructuring triggers
a kind of amazing feeling of awe and
wonder of being small and have limitless
possibilities and if you seek these
moments and increase your exposure to
the novel and the new and the exciting
then you could be naturally far more
inventive and creative so thanks ton for
watching guys hope you found this video
useful and interesting if you did please
leave a like comment down below let me
know you think and of course I've got
many more like this on the way on brain
training fitness bodybuilding martial
arts you name it productivity so if that
sounds good then please subscribe hit
the bell button for notifications and
I'll see you next time thanks a ton for
watching bye for now